I think we in the Western World in the
First World
um
have a a privilege and we don't realize
that food is really to many people
around the world a luxury and
like if you're a a young person that is
not hungry I'm sorry that is hungry and
you're in one of these countries and
you're look like you're working hard at
school all day and you're waiting for
that bowl of shark fin soup when you get
home and you go I work hard all day at
school and then you're driving a
rickshaw a literal Rickshaw through the
mountains with your panda friend and
you're going up hills and up and down
the hills and then you get to this
lovely little rustic
little Chinese kind of like bamboo it's
very it's kind of well appointed and you
and your panda friend get out and mom
goes hey and here's the shark fin soup
that's someone's culture
so to me
what you're suggesting is like someone
goes oh I have a culture but it doesn't
matter because you want them instead of
that to go through McDonald's get 15
cheeseburgers and like you know like
start like I don't know vaping by the
mall but they're like no no no no no no
we have a culture too and it's eating
this soup I asked them about that it
actually started in the 1960s there was
a story that one of the Emperors in the
year 800 said I want to eat a shark
because that's the strongest animal and
I want to be stronger than that so then
in the 1960s the restaurants the hotels
were like what if we served it as a
gimmick and just to get people to stay
here and have their weddings here and
then in 2000 China really started
getting money or 90s took off it became
a really expensive item but the problem
with the soup is that nobody likes it
because it tastes like nothing it's
actually fishing wire so they have to
put chicken stock in pork stock and they
have to scrub it with bleach now the
bleach they scrub it with is the same
stuff you clean your toilet with it has
neurotoxins the bleach does not come out
they have have to scrub it bleach it
dehydrate it rehydrate and it only just
feels like if you bit your fingernail
that's exactly what it tastes like so
fairness so so I'm describing 85 of
American fast food exactly as well
there's a lot there's plastic in the
yoga mats at Subway I know I'm sorry
there's yoga mat plastic in the bread
yoga yeah the yoga mats the yoga at
Subway but you know what I mean like
like you're making good points but then
they will turn around and they will go
you're serving people plastic they can
they can say it but here's the thing the
Young Generation in China I I asked them
I go what what they don't want it at
their wedding it's the parents are doing
it to show off and I said that you know
I said you I don't listen to the younger
generation because they don't believe in
Tradition they don't believe in values
there many of them have been raised on
the internet they're sick and if you're
gonna have a shark fin soup a
traditional shark fin soup at the
wedding
and you know if you're having food that
has actually no flavor and causes
impotence in brain damage which it does
with the neurotoxins in the fin and and
to even get it to taste like anything
you have to flavor it with either but
it's delicacy and it is a flex it's it's
a flex but they but what we realized
fake bear it's not 50. dummies but we
realized fake if you have an expensive
bowl of mushroom soup or lobster soup
people are just as happy and we talked
to everybody so the young people in
China are over this are over and the
older people are just like we just want
to show off give something expensive and
treat our guests well so a lot of people
destroy every tradition that's ever
existed on the planet like this is my
this is a fake tradition it's it's it
was a marketing gimmick it was never a
tradition it's not like oh by the way
the Pharaoh Islands you know they kill
them if you ever sat down with one of
these fishermen and have they really
opened your mind
you know when you sit down with a
fisherman like a yeah a a hearty kind of
old salt from Massachusetts who's like
you know I heard the Sharks must be
eating yeah but really though has any
has anybody opened your mind to the
necessity of this is there do you see
any of the arguments from the other side
at all the only thing I can see is that
in a place like Indonesia uh they're
starving and eating shark because
there's a lack of protein that's that's
a serious issue because Indonesia but
what I've seen mainly is that it's like
the mafia is very involved in Spain
there's they're a huge Spain is the
number one exporter of fins it's a
completely useless trade there's not a
single person where I sat down I was
like and that's why you see me in the
documentary and I go crazy I'm like but
I don't understand it like the soup has
no flavor it caught it has neurotoxins
none of the health stuff like what is it
and then it's like oh everyone's just
making money from killing them so why
stop it that's really the answer well I
mean listen at the end of the day it's
it it's certainly you have an opinion
and I think that it's valid and I think
you've done research into it
um and I think that like there's is
there not a happy medium
oh can we not meet in the middle what is
the middle though the middle would be
viewing chalks as violent Predators yes
protecting ourselves against them by
means of well I don't know but
but you've been in the water your whole
life you've never even seen one a sand
shark once swam into me and was
disgusted don't you think that's racist
isn't that the definition of racism as
you've heard things about you have
actually no experience whatsoever with
sharks none everything is from what
someone has told you and what you've
read in the news you've never
experienced one you've been in the water
your whole life and yet you still
believe this That's How Strong the media
is don't you see the brainwashing that's
been the last 40 years that's what the
fishing industry wants they like us to
be terrified and angry and petrified of
them instead of saying going we need
them respect them protect them but let's
figure out a way
I'm only sometimes on a plane if I have
nothing to do
and I have the Wi-Fi I will watch shark
attacks like a lot of people
and
ironic and fun to do in a plane but I'll
watch shark attacks because I want to
know what's going on and I want to know
what I'm up against and this idea that
sharks Eli are not violent when they are
apex predators is crazy but that's not
my position my position is please don't
kill them we need them okay but also how
about please don't kill us two sharks
well there's a lot of other things that
guy in Egypt why is the tiger shark
eating him I don't know
tiger shark but the tiger sharks it's a
tragedy it's a tragedy people are going
to die like we can't protect we can't
child proof the world we can't you know
what about a gate no I'm literally
saying what about if they tried people
have tried it it doesn't work why
because you can't build it in the ocean
the ocean moves you can't like build
something that sits in the ocean that
keeps sharks out we have drones that
watch the Sharks and can we send
threatening things down like not not
just not just we just there's a horn
they do shark spotters they just there's
a shark people move out five minutes
late shark passes most of the time the
sharks are there swimming with us
we never know it because they don't want
they're afraid of interaction I'm
telling you they only go after things
they know they're going to eat and they
don't eat that often they're pelagic
they wander the globe eating the sick
and dying fish that's what they want and
so when we're splashing around that's
mimicking that like when a fish is
injured well I don't like splashing and
I don't do it a lot anyway because it's
very it's kind of like low rent Behavior
well you know we have to float kind of
like you know
uh you know like you just kind of like
just be quiet I don't like a lot of
splashing I don't like a lot of loud
music on the beach I don't like a lot of
fast food you know like a certain type
of beach I like a couple of women in
white linens for quiet women don't go in
the ocean it's a little gross and the
men will go into the children or the the
housekeeper will bring the children in
but the women sit there a little white
linen on the beach reading a novel I so
there's certain type of beaches that I
don't go to I mean and God forbid and
God help us we know a lot of what's
going on in the beaches right now it's
crazy
um but I'm just saying you know I've
always been a person who believes that
human beings are a special and unique
thing
I know that about you no I believe that
and would you ban smoking I mean you're
an advocate of smoking well not always
but I think there's times when a
cigarette will make a situation more
livable
um uh but no I I I I wouldn't ban
smoking what I would say to people is
you know
I believe human beings are special and
unique and I believe they have dominion
over the animals and the beasts a lot of
people do and I and I don't even believe
that
necessarily in a theological Christian
way I believe in it in a we are smarter
than them we are sharper and we have
been able to do things like make things
like drive-throughs and nuclear weapons
and uh all-inclusive resorts and things
that people may not like but
they're nice did you know that great
white sharks speak with mouth gaping
they do this a lot
these little jaw movements and move
their fins and is that speaking that's
how they communicate and what do they
say well they go down in the bottom they
decide who's going to go up to breach
they have an order they discuss it
amongst themselves you'll never see two
sharks breach on a seal now can you
speak in mouth gaping and fin movements
no but a lot of people I grew up with
can well so a lot of those people decide
through mouth gaping and fin movements
who's going to talk to what girl and
who's going to get in what car exactly
so there's a lot of human beings that
behave in a certain way I'm just saying
I I here's what I say and this is maybe
the the the the resolution let's all
just lighten up right right because
you're making these very depressing
things about oh there's all the killing
and the shark let's lighten up the
Spanish Mafia let's let's all have some
wine and relax let's not go here and
tell everyone how to live that's my only
problem I go it's not am I out there
killing a shark with a knife no but I'm
very much let's Live and Let Live let's
let people around the world do the
things they want and if it's your
culture to have the shark fin soup at
the wedding I don't know if it's my job
as a western American to tell you how to
live I believe that we all share a
planet